MALE SPEAKER: Don't worry.
We're good?
Great.
Welcome back to Devoxx.
And we're here this time
to talk about, well, I
think, Android, right?
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: This is Romain.
This is Chet.
Or is it the other way around?
ROMAIN GUY: We're
not sure anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I'm not sure either.
So welcome guys,
welcome back to Devoxx.
You've been here many years.
And this is the second time
in a row that you're here
announcing, almost, the
release of something,
following the release.
CHET HAASE: Maybe.
Maybe we try to time the
platform releases with Devoxx.
Maybe more positive coincidence.
MALE SPEAKER: So it's
Devoxx-driven development.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
That's a new process.
I think you're going
to talk about it.
It's a new patterns.
CHET HAASE: There is a
process talk tomorrow.
So maybe.
MALE SPEAKER:
Yeah, make sure you
don't miss that one on Parlays.
It'll be on Parlays, right?
CHET HAASE: I hope so.
MALE SPEAKER: If
it's good, only.
So it should be there.
So we're here to talk
about Android 4.4.
That's KitKat, the
KitKat release.
So we announced two things,
obviously, the software, 4.4,
and some hardware, I think.
CHET HAASE: I think there's some
new hardware-- oh wait, there's
some in my hand.
ROMAIN GUY: You
happen to have it.
What a coincidence.
CHET HAASE: So this is an
example of the Nexus 5.
This is the white
model, white on black,
as well as the black on black.
Both colors.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, good.
Two colors available in a number
of countries from day one?
ROMAIN GUY: Yes.
I don't remember which ones.
Many countries, not enough.
MALE SPEAKER: Not enough.
It's never enough.
CHET HAASE: I think the
US, and the other ones
are a little more vague tome.
MALE SPEAKER: So
there are a number
of European countries
for those watching us
in Europe, certainly.
Anything you want to
point out about the device
other than the fact
that it runs KitKat
which we'll talk
about in a second.
ROMAIN GUY: I love the screen.
The screen's amazing.
CHET HAASE: High resolution,
fast, smooth, nice.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, the
colors are really good.
And it's super fast, the device.
CHET HAASE: You
just like the screen
because it has your
wallpaper on it.
MALE SPEAKER: Great, so
let's talk about KitKat 4.4.
Does the numbering,
first of all,
mean anything in terms
of how much features
went into this one?
CHET HAASE: It's actually
exactly 0.1 better
than the previous release.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
That's a good start.
CHET HAASE: I would
say the distinction
on the dot releases, correct
me if I'm wrong is, API bump.
So there could be some new APIs
that you could take advantage
of.
If we're not changing the APIs,
generally, we wouldn't do that.
It wouldn't be more like
a maintenance release
on what we've previously done.
ROMAIN GUY: It's a question
for marketing engineers.
We don't decide the
version numbers.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Next question.
ROMAIN GUY: We just come up
with features, and we fix bugs.
MALE SPEAKER: Good enough.
Good enough.
OK, fine, fair enough.
Animation framework.
Is that something new?
Now why even have
something like that?
CHET HAASE: Users
demand animations.
So it's been my personal goal
to make animations almost
automatic, as far
as they can be.
So I realize everybody likes
to think about animations as
much as I do, but they probably
don't have the time to.
So the more that we can do
to make it easy for them,
I think the better
the animations are
going to be in the applications.
So the main thing that
we did this time--
we have all kinds of
animation capabilities
already, but you have to
write a fair amount of code
to get really good animations.
We made it easier to do
transitional animations.
And in fact, the feature
is called transitions.
And you can, basically,
say start a transition now,
change your UI by
inflating new layouts
or modifying the
views that are there.
And, on the next frame,
it will automatically
detect what the
changes are in the UI
and run some sort
of automatic image.
MALE SPEAKER: And that's an
API, or is it declarative?
CHET HAASE: It's both.
You can declare
resources where you
state this information
ahead of time,
in addition to layout files.
Or you can, in your code,
simply say, OK, change the UI
accordingly, call this method
on the transition's interface.
So this is in the
transition package.
ROMAIN GUY: You've basically
programmed itself out
of your job.
CHET HAASE: It
wasn't the intention,
but I'll have to see whether
my badge works when I go home.
ROMAIN GUY: You should
go talk to your manager
as well when you come back.
MALE SPEAKER: There was one
neat feature that I found,
which is full screen,
or there's probably
a better name for that.
ROMAIN GUY: The immersive mode.
MALE SPEAKER: Immersive mode.
OK.
ROMAIN GUY: So.
It's something
that we had before.
So it's the ability to get
rid of the system UI, the nav
bar, and the status bar.
So some apps, we're able
to do it, video playback,
for instance.
But now it's open
to all applications.
We're going to talk
about it in details.
And I'll talk what's
new in Android.
There's going to be some code.
It's very easy to use
and makes a lot of sense
for games or immersive
content like books, magazines,
things like that.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
CHET HAASE: You can
think of the main change
being that you can have a
full screen application where
the user can actually
interact with the application
while remaining full
screen, as opposed to,
as soon as they tap,
the bars come back in,
which was the previous behavior.
MALE SPEAKER: So how
do I exit that mode?
ROMAIN GUY: You can swipe
from the top or swipe
from the bottom, and
you get the bars back.
MALE SPEAKER: Can
my kids do that?
I hope they can't.
ROMAIN GUY: They can, but
if they learn the gesture.
CHET HAASE: How
smart are your kids?
MALE SPEAKER: Let's
not get there.
Another thing I
like, and we'll try
not to go through
all the features.
And there'll be a great talk.
I'm sure you guys will
deliver available on Parlays.
Another interesting feature
is screen recording.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
Awesome for developers.
MALE SPEAKER: Because, I
mean, it's great for you guys.
Probably, it's
great for developers
for showcasing their
apps on the store.
How does it work?
ROMAIN GUY: For
the developer, it's
great both because they can
showcase their app on websites.
They don't have to use the
shaky cam version of recording.
It's also really
useful for debugging.
You can go frame by
frame in your video.
And you can see if there's a
glitch, or performance issue,
you can see that.
That's actually how
we did most of that.
So right now, there's a
command line tool with ADB.
You type ADB shell
screen record.
And you get to an MPEG-4.
Or from Android Studio,
there's a new button.
In one click, you
can record a video.
The only limitation right
now is that you can only
record up to three minutes.
That's it.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Good.
But there's no triggering
those directly from the phone
like you can take a screen shot?
ROMAIN GUY: Not at the moment.
MALE SPEAKER: Not yet.
OK, good.
Project Svelte?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: So you guys
talked about Butter last year.
Butter was not good after all,
and we need to go on a diet.
What's the deal there?
CHET HAASE: You know, all
diets are in cycles anyway.
So a little too much Butter,
a little more diet needed.
MALE SPEAKER: So this
is about running on--
CHET HAASE: On
lower end devices.
MALE SPEAKER: End devices.
So how do you define this?
CHET HAASE: 512 megabytes
is what we aimed at
to run reasonably well on.
It turns out that there's
still a bunch of devices
still coming out in the market
new with older releases.
And the reason is because
the newer releases simply
had too much memory footprint
for them to run comfortably.
Not enough applications
could run simultaneously.
So what we've done is slim
down the entire platform
to make it easier to run more
applications in only Svelte.
MALE SPEAKER: So how did
you actually do that?
Is that at the OS
level, at the app level,
everywhere you could shave off?
ROMAIN GUY: Everywhere
it's new tools,
new APIs, lots of
work in the OS itself.
So new kernel features.
A lot of changes
in the framework.
We've also analyzed
all the apps.
And the app developers
worked great in optimizing
the applications.
So today, we gave a
bunch of tips and tricks
on what you can do, what tools
can you use in your apps,
and what you can do to
use less memory yourself.
And it's very important
because there are lot of users
out there with phones
with-- it's still
a lot of memory,
512 megs of RAM.
You want as many
apps as possible
to run at the same time.
MALE SPEAKER: Do
you want to talk
about prog stats, enhancements?
And performance
tools in general?
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, so,
I mean, we come up
with new tools in
every release to help
the team itself
optimize the platform.
And we make those
tools available.
So everything we've used on
Project Svelte and Project
Butter before that,
those are tools
made available to
developers in KitKat.
CHET HAASE: In fact,
the tips that we talked
about in the session that
we had earlier today,
it was tips for
Android developers.
But they really came
from our own experience.
It's the approaches that we
use, the tools that we use,
and the optimizations
that we implement
to make the platform smaller.
And maybe developers can
think about the same things
to make their applications
smaller as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Another new feature
is printing support?
CHET HAASE: Yes, excellent.
MALE SPEAKER: Based on PDF.
So it's not just for printing.
It's also for generating PDFs.
ROMAIN GUY: That's
actually the side effect
of adding support for printing.
You can generate PDFs.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Well, you can look at
it both ways, I suppose.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
But they are pretty independent.
So if your applications,
if you want
to be able to export PDFs to
just email them, or store them
somewhere else, you don't
have to use the printing APIs.
MALE SPEAKER: So speaking
of physical printers,
which ones can you print to?
What's the protocols you use?
ROMAIN GUY: So any Cloud
Print enabled device.
So if you have Cloud
Print on your desktop,
it's going to work with
pretty much any printer.
If you have a Cloud
Print enabled printer,
it works directly.
And you can also
install plug-ins.
So on the Nexus 5, we
ship with the HP plug-in.
So any HP printer or recent
HP printer will work.
And I'm sure there'll be more
plug-ins on the Play Store
very soon.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Awesome.
Storage Access Framework?
CHET HAASE: Yes, it's a
concept of documents and sort
of unified access to
different places where
you can store things.
So your application
no longer needs
to figure out how do I access
the area in SD card, where
I want to put it,
or on the cloud.
Or if you're a service
that provides storage,
like a Dropbox or
whatever, out in the cloud,
you don't need to figure out
how to expose that to users.
Instead, there's a unified way
to both publish your storage
mechanism as well
as for the user
to access the published
storage mechanisms.
MALE SPEAKER: So yeah.
So it's good for providers
as well as users.
It's like a modern version
of an open dialogue and file
chooser, that type of thing?
ROMAIN GUY: That's exactly it.
MALE SPEAKER: OK cool.
ROMAIN GUY: It's
document-oriented.
It's not file-oriented.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
document-oriented.
OK, that works.
OK, the WebView.
The WebView is based
on Chromium now.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, so big news.
Based on Chromium.
So brand new
implementation, same APIs.
Some of them have
been deprecated,
but it's a drop-in replacement.
Nothing to do in your apps.
It runs on Chromium.
MALE SPEAKER: You don't
actually have a choice, right?
ROMAIN GUY: No, you
don't have a choice.
Which is good because it
does better HTML5 support.
The Chromium team is constantly
working on improving things.
You also get remote debugging.
So for USB, you can
use Chrome to remove
debug on the phone,
which is really useful.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
So we had a lot of people
trying it out and then having
some features, finding out new
things they can do with it.
Because with Chromium
comes support
for a set of new
features around HTML5,
and they're all new
apps that you can build.
ROMAIN GUY: So I haven't seen
new apps taking advantage
of HTML5 yet, but I'm sure we'll
see that coming very shortly.
MALE SPEAKER: Right, because
this is where support for HTML5
will come, and in the
browser and Android.
Let's see.
One more thing I had
was SMS Provider.
ROMAIN GUY: So we've had an API.
It was a hidden API that a
lot of people were using.
It was not enough show API.
So now we have enough show
API to access the SMSs
on the phone.
And we have the concept of
the default SMS application.
So only the default
SMS application
as chosen by the user will
be able to write to the SMS
database.
But now, at least we have
show support for that.
But we let the user in control.
MALE SPEAKER: Great.
Two more things I want to
cover before we close this.
One is tooling.
Can you say few words
on Android Studio?
There's a lot of work
going on on this.
And [INAUDIBLE] or Xavier
are not here with us
at this conference.
CHET HAASE: Yeah,
so on their behalf,
I'll talk about all
the work that they've
done that I'm not aware of.
There's obviously work going
on on the tools all the time
anyway.
But there's been a huge
effort behind Android Studio.
It's still early
release, beta release,
I forget what the
official terminology is.
ROMAIN GUY: It's the
Google I/O preview.
CHET HAASE: Strangely, 0.3.4
just came out this week.
And it provides
one of the changes
is, there's some
language level changes.
So you can now take advantage of
things like strings and switch
statements--
MALE SPEAKER: I want to get
to that, absolutely, yeah.
CHET HAASE: Diamond operators,
the multi exception catch,
and the resource closing.
I forget.
ROMAIN GUY: To measure
resource management.
CHET HAASE: So the cool thing
about these language features
is that all of them,
except the last one,
the resource management is they
are available on any platform
release because the [INAUDIBLE]
Compiler basically will just
compile it to whatever
it needs to be.
It's kind of syntactic
sugar, right?
The resource management
is capability
of the platform you
need to do target SDK.
MALE SPEAKER: Because
there's an interface
you need to implement.
ROMAIN GUY: There's
an interface.
MALE SPEAKER: So that was
the, actually, last point
I want to get to is that
you get all those language
evolution which,
actually, a lot of them
do make sense for
Android developers.
So there's multi-catch--
ROMAIN GUY: I'm pretty
excited for those features.
MALE SPEAKER: Auto-closable is
a pretty important one as well.
ROMAIN GUY: And
download the features
too, divided support
for drawable previews.
The integrated
[INAUDIBLE] better.
So you can start screen
recording from Android Studio
directly.
There's a new trace
view UI that's
very similar to sys
trace, [INAUDIBLE] to use.
I mean, they're coming out
with new releases all the time.
And every time they do
a pretty amazing job
at coming up with new features.
So yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, great.
ROMAIN GUY: It's exciting.
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, I guess guys,
that's all the time
we have for it.
Thanks for showing up
with our friend here.
And I think go get there,
and then use those APIs,
and then provide feedback.
That's our call to action here.
ROMAIN GUY: Thanks.
CHET HAASE: Sounds good, thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.